c'est la coutume et des lunettes pour
moi c'est pas toi tu mets des lunettes
comme moi c'est vous que mal copié
ah oui bah oui je progresse comme ça on
avec la victoire et arles briques à des
gens sérieux là et il ya des gens
sérieux ce travail avec denisot sa
canette je voulais couper le talon 60
talent tu veux je te dise non mais
attendez qu'on a du talent fadila les
yeux fermés depuis des années mais sert
à rien de ressasser que peut pas
toujours dire bordel c'est déjà du lourd
cette semaine vous êtes au courant
d'accord très bien sûr et vous
rappellent à chaque base chronique et
captait ya une nouvelle rubrique cyril
que j'ai décidé de lancer ouais je me
suis incrusté cette semaine dans les
loges alors je rappelle un jeu je
dénonce tout je vois tout je suis dans
les loges je regarde tout ce qui se
passe pendant les pubs pendant les
magnétos et vous allez voir cyril je
tiens ça sent pas bon moi non non ça il
a dit qu'il a des chaussures sur le feu
nous devons faire cela il est acheté le
week-end dernier pour les soldes sur un
traîneau ma mère et je connais il a pris
deux tailles au dessus absolument il les
a demandé des amendements car entériné
avec en 44 connais je sais pas je
regarde je vois bien que c'est ma tombe
les gens voient bien que c'est pas ton
pied c'est mon art est de 3 g 10 mai de
chaises mais arrête de donner quoi de
quoi on est touché c'est pas des
chaussures des 60 de te dire et leur âme
et à rennes ça touche au bout mais pas
du tout merci mais non je te joindre aux
pieds
voilà nommé nonce à 13 h
non coire et c'est pas proportionnel
cité pied mais c'est le constat des jets
d'être là et s'il savait si tes pieds
vont au bout frères savons gels étant
donné qu'elle est plus grand que sa
personne mais pas du tout est prêt
personnel chez marc isolé et ateba bosse
il ya des choses du combien ai-je du 43
quoi je vous promets je suis prêt à les
enlever
arrête toi mais 43 de sa valeur que les
mac imac et mesure avec 88,6 m'habitue
radieux et balshaw celle du 90 mais pas
du tout mais je sais que je pourrai
voulait prêter où vous rentrez de grâce
à ce genre de patois évasif et à
contretemps airs de pop boxill j'ai
décidé de lancer une nouvelle rubrique
dans indique de la rédac ouais je suis
parti dans les loges je me suis incrusté
et 6e du dossier en bas figurez vous
qu'il en a encore plus en os os et j'ai
tout ramené et vous savez vous savez
qu'il les a compilé pour vous qu'est
séjour luc attention à la loge
oui on va pas faire un peu d'anti alors
le principe me dit que jean luc
reichmann
il est étonné de tout ce qu'on me dit il
étonné tout étonné je fais qu'en dit la
wii salut les 12 coups de midi
c'est maintenant et je suis avec pierre
bonjour pierre bonjour dans les 11 euros
pierre venu nous raconter une petite
anecdote c'était le jour de votre bac
exactement alors j'arrive le jour de mon
bac en fait c'était pâques histoire
géographie et le matin j'avais révisé en
fait toute la guerre 39 45
c'est pas possible
[Rires]
[Musique]
ok a dit alors va dire oui et donc dans
ce cas de tourner il a en a qu'un
candidat nous sommes avec richard
bonjour richard bon salaire venu dans
les 12 coups de midi
et qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé avec
votre ex je crois qu'il me disait alors
non en fait c'est très simple c'est que
j'avais une ex qui s'appelait mathilde
wii est en fait la nouvelle femme
s'appelle mathilde à et je voulais
envoyer un texto à matilda et je
l'envoyais à matisse mais c'est génial
effet que je dis oui mais attention à la
salle us et jean luc bienvenu dans
attention à la loge
on commence avec un bernard montiel
comme ça ça va les prostituées l'aquila
dix paires les cov le rythme dans la
peau
n'attendons pas grammes or notre os du
talon elles manquent d'eau vivent on
n'est pas là
et on passe tout est la question qu la
question avec benjamin goetz de moi ni
mes parents 4 pouces à me casser
[Rires]
attention attention bernard apprend
beaucoup de choses dans les loges aurait
appris quoi comme roman d'annie ta mère
mais ça va presque c'est après encore ta
grand mère en 5 des nodules ce style là
sueur sans chroniqueurs qui est en bas
ils n'ont pas de vie méconnue car oui à
un bal des incendies non ils n'ont pas
vie professionnelle parce que d'ailleurs
à monaco aux affaires tps vais tous les
soirs mais à côté vraiment à moi je
reçois des messages tous les jours tous
les jours tous les lauréats lors
pourquoi tu es plus à gtp mais comment
ça se fait qu'on ne voit plus à tête
pembe enfin contre agen tout ça je suis
parti bien sûr parce que moi j'adore
syrie non mais tu es le chlore ni kuna
[Musique]
c'est confirmé bernard montiel et un
crevard vous aime bien quand même
[Musique]
darwich
c'est pas mal les albigeois il avait mis
des caméras dans cette voie et
j'embrasse famille a le coeur qui est
formidable
oui même bien il va m'en vouloir je me
faisais un an ils m'aiment bien
attention à la je voulais dit oui cela
fait maintenant voilà ton chien là il
faut faire gaffe parce que je suis là je
sors mais tout quoi voilà je peux
continuer à rester sur cette séquence
combattre parce que cette semaine
il ya une grosse actu médias il ya deux
sujets le premier sujet c'est ce bug là
vous savez à la régie tf1 et puis il ya
eu la bouche de benjamin castaldi shawey
oui alors oui thomas je te le dis si tu
arrive je soupçonne bachand agassi et
c'est son droit d'avoir fait gonfler sa
bouche
non mais tu tu as le droit sérieux et
oui tu as le droit mais non parce que je
veux pas le regarder dans les neiges
mais il a fait ça ces endroits c'est
bien sûr quelque chose moi c'est pas
grave moi j'adore emmanuelle béart vrai
qu'on avait c'est vrai et bien at il
d'autres évocations très belle série est
très belle
il ya là plein qu'ils ont fait il va la
trump et ya quelque chose il paraît que
à des femmes en fait là depuis un an
parce que j'ai pas de d'exemple d'hommes
pour l'instant et à qui johnny johnny
des ouïes pas médioni fait ce qu'il veut
surtout il fait ce qu'il peut aulas
l'oreille sorti boire la wii si
conséquences car est ce qu'il a c'est
quelque chose qui arrive
eh bien figurez vous que vos équipes ont
mené l enquête et on a des réponses
[Musique]
tout a commencé un soir de tpm pays
castaldi n'est pas bien mais six ans
mais on fait la bouche ou quadras caf un
truc à ta bouche cousue arias maintenant
offerte à la bouche diva d'après connard
colomba n'était qu'au début d'une
enquête au qu'il a toujours le don pour
parler de choses qui sont différentes
que ce que vise la manière des gens
merci nos bouches colomba tente tout
pour lui faire avouer sa voiture le
départ ce secteur là qu'est et pose la
question tu vois toujours bouffer des
tâches colomba bas on voit ses meilleurs
éléments sur le dossier collombat bas
avec des infiltrés partout jusque dans
les loges benjamin s'avère coriace il
continue de nier il était cuit guillaume
genton l'inspecteur de la 1re division
avaient toutes les preuves
un document confidentiel
comment sur les amène à fait pleine
opération chine mais bien sûr que c'est
toujours la boule de feu - vont envoyer
la liste de ces opérations
si c'est un vieux épiderme non lifting
vegan des pectoraux mais non épilation
intégrale du siphon miel de châtaignier
que ce soit de siffler si on t'a fait
s'il allait encore une enquête résolue
par trop longs baba et si jésus mais
bravo l'artiste
[Musique]
et voilà c'est pas parce que tu veux tu
as an mais juste je te dirais qui tu
fais confié thérèse bus a fait fermer
les yeux
non mais jolie qui pensent qu'il a fait
a bien sûr mais vous êtes des malades
c'est sur wii s'y tient non non je crois
que peut-être il a testé au maquillage
elle qui fait gonfler les lèvres il a
voulu se faire un kiff avant de faire
l'opération en fait vous allez dire que
des conneries la demande et du rouge à
lèvres voici une fois qu'il a il a
taillé différemment sa moustache qui est
exceptionnel peut dire c'est pas ravi
c'est chauffé ce week-end le mec donne
accès gratuit vient on connaît encore
des cas très bien mais sans égal et
voilà c'est vrai il se retrouve avec un
zodiac au milieu de la bouche c'est
passionnant et homogène c'est quand
cyril vous savez chaque semaine je
réunis un peu tout ce qui se passe
pendant les pubs pendant les magnétos
ses 50 secondes inside
[Rires]
salut à tous et bienvenue dans sa
cantine inside du pmp et on commence
tout de suite avec baba qui était très
agité surtout bilingue cette semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
visiblement la météo ne s'arrange pas
pour bernard qui s'est pris un vent de
force 5 dont c'est que le rafale peut en
cacher une autre
dans dix ans il en riant brésil on
continue avec guillaume surtout en
pleine remise en question vestimentaire
mais moi je pense que ça tient bien mais
l'egypte est encore une fois comme le
dit cyril met à les marquer c'est pas du
tout son délire à sa grand mère sa grand
mère sa grand-mère à nice à ce qu'aulas
walia et au parlant de mater les marques
et scoop on sait enfin pourquoi
jean-pierre arrêter le trésor mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce corps douves
mais je sais pourquoi jean pierre
pernaut à rethel 13 heures montiel c'est
vraiment le plus aimé de la bande kenyan
moto aujourd'hui tu t'emmerdes castaldi
benjamin genton
c'est vraiment l'amour fou mais l'islam
ou pas c'est vrai
6h du mat
les cathos de 8 ans est nu
malheureusement entre l'amour et la
haine ne t'en fais la gueule et on finit
avec baba pour qui l'amitié c'est
vraiment quelque chose de secret on
touche pana billard ce monde année ban
et vous pouvez la dépouille la défense
et mais c'est mon ami c'est vraiment
bien c'est mon avis or c'est à dire les
choses donc ça prouve mais je vous jésus
juste dit nabila c'est mon ami c'est
vrai que c'est bon après tout c'était
gentil avec elle c'est vrai que voilà
voilà c'est passé dans le pense ou parce
que mais je vous ai dit c'est parce que
moi c'est parce que c'est mon ami non
pas d'une on s'en fout que soit votre
mii quoi comme je les aime beaucoup
moins par contre vous êtes de plus en
plus insolent vous voulez à l'elysée
tous à vous d'être peut-être un jour
analyser tout ça en baissant régulier il
ya un an mais parce que lui c'est quand
même bernard montiel quoi maintenant
c'est que c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
est au plus haut sommet de l'état
ok pour trois ans je m'en tire on va pas
se raconter d'histoires il est pas plus
intelligent peso mais il est utopique et
non à yayi attention c'est quelqu'un
d'important là d'accord quand vous dire
il peut faire sauter des contraventions
la c1 ou pas ça va vous sinon j'avais
très bien merci beaucoup d'acteurs moi
très bonne mêlée pose là quoi ce
week-end qui fait aucune idée d'accord
il faut que je termine le livre d'eric
emmanuel schmitt 500 pages laissé une
belle histoire avec emmanuel schmitt
j'adore bah oui lorsqu'il fait j'ai fait
une bêtise et une cuisine de chacun
[Rires]
alors j'allais dire que l'émission
aurait passé un step qu'on était passé
dans une émission sérieuse simplement
l'émission cyril en ce moment à la
bâtisse machika c'est un gros club c'est
entendu tout à eric vogica lui embrasse
tous les gens qui font des cuisines bien
entendu de faire cirer l'émission en ce
moment là passez un step on parle de
sujets sérieux à l'après-11 autre angle
alors vous recevez pour cela des
médecins des heures animé tiens oui y'en
a marre des gens qui avaient plein des
avocats aussi bien sûr des avocats j'en
connais plein des épidémiologistes
assure j'en connais plein dit pas des
boucs tu comptais pas des éditorialistes
et baba et sait recevoir
franchement y'a rien à dire sauf que
bayard sur de deux manières ya celle que
vous voyez vous à la maison très gentil
très sympa en direct et puis il ya
celles 30 secondes avant pendant les
magnétos où il dit bonjour et vous allez
voir c'est pas du tout pareil
j'espère que c'est pas fait
la vie de notre docteur julien borovick
c'est quelqu'un de sérieux bon tonique
décerné à bord avec c'est comme si vous
étiez le chef technique
j'adore julio plus à manger la mire
vajou bis qui est là également merci à
vous deux est bien karl olive merci
d'être avec nous je sais que de nombreux
plateaux télé voulez vous avoir ce soir
comment ça va car on veut passer
inaperçu t'es mieux à poissy que c'est
nous les séries on à martin blachier qui
est là on a même une mett re division
qui est là merci d'être là bas vous
défoncer je le connais fabrice pas vous
défoncer peut pas vous plairait sont pas
vos blairiste lépine et fabrice tu
restes après pour le sujet est tendue
par l'inertie fabrice tôt l'âge mûr ya
là m carlo abrite à alberto carlos ruiz
à merci comment ça va car l'eau monte
carlo verser l'état mais des dossiers
officiels
tu vas pas être que tu vas lire tout ça
car l'eau et on a on a notre ami alors
lucien cohen devait être une sommité
dans le monde voilà de la dératisation
mabrouk a le blues ont trempé
jimmy
on est là pour être sérieux et leurs
genoux un papa et c'est même ça
[Applaudissements]
j'étais bien j'étais bien ensuite aux
mouches abbaoui magnifique
on y fera corps à corps mais si tu as
bien bossé un oui pas mal de dos et un
merci et et sa figure et vous la semaine
prochaine j'en ai encore plus l'accord à
quoi fait bon week end à l'indic là
c'est quand je vois des gens comme ça je
vois d'ici là